everyone is cowering and afraid in the
face of what we're seeing now but not
everyone it turns out there is good news
you may have seen the recent letter from
a father at the brearley school in new
york he wrote it to
parents at the school hundreds of them
barely is a private girls school in the
upper east side of manhattan it's where
some of the richest most famous people
in the world send their daughters and
have for more than 100 years it's a
famously good school
burley has long been a liberal place but
over the past year like so many schools
in this country it has become
cultish and totalitarian a parent called
andrew
gutman finally said so here's part of
what he wrote
quote our family recently made the
decision not to re-enroll our daughter
at breerley for the 2021-22 school year
she's been at burley for seven years
beginning in kindergarten
in short we no longer believe that
briley's administration and board of
trustees
have any of our children's best
interests at heart
it cannot be stated strongly enough that
brealy's obsession with race
must stop the administration the board
of trustees have displayed a cowardly
and appalling lack of leadership by
appeasing an anti-intellectual illiberal
mob
and then allowing the school to be
captured by that same mob
i object to the view that i should be
judged by the color of my skin
i cannot tolerate a school that not only
judges my daughter by the color of her
skin
but encourages and instructs her to
pre-judge others by theirs
by viewing every element of education
every aspect of history every facet of
society
through the lens of skin color and race
we are desecrating the legacy of dr
martin luther king jr
and we're utterly violating the movement
for which such civil rights leaders
believed fought and died
i object to the charge of systemic
racism in this country and at our school
we've not had systemic racism against
african americans in this country since
the civil rights reforms
of the 1960s a period of more than 50
years
to state otherwise is a flat-out
misrepresentation of our country's
history
and it adds no understanding to any of
today's societal issues
if anything long-standing and widespread
policies such as affirmative action
point in precisely the opposite
direction breerly by adopting critical
race theory
is advocating the abhorrent viewpoint
that black americans should
forever be regarded as helpless victims
and are incapable of success
regardless of their skills talents or
hard work
what really is teaching our children is
precisely the true and correct
definition of racism
i object to brierly's vacuous
inappropriate and fanatical use of the
words
equity diversity and inclusiveness if
briley's administration was truly
concerned about so-called equity
it would be discussing the cessation of
admissions preferences for legacies
siblings and those families with
especially deep pockets
let's pause now and smile because that's
so true if the administration was
genuinely serious about diversity
it would not insist on the
indoctrination of its students and their
families to a single mindset most
reminiscent of the chinese
cultural revolution instead the school
would foster an environment of
intellectual openness and freedom of
thought
and if barely really cared about
inclusiveness
the school would return to the concepts
encapsulated in the motto one brearly
instead of teaching the extraordinarily
divisive idea that there are
only and always two groups in this
country victims and oppressors
i object to the censorship of books that
have been taught for generations because
they contain dated language
potentially offensive to the thin
skinned and hypersensitive
something that's already happened in my
daughter's fourth grade class i object
to the lowering of standards for the
admissions of students and for the
hiring of teachers
i object to the erosion of rigor in
class work and the escalation of great
inflation
our nation will not survive a generation
of leadership
even more poorly educated than what we
have now nor will we survive a
generation of students taught
to hate its own country and despise its
own history
the letter goes on like this the entire
thing is worth reading
and it's worth sending to everyone you
know it is brilliant
why isn't this guy running the country
how did the school respond to the letter
the school didn't respond
burly's head mistress a semi-literate
called jane freed
just dismissed it out of hand as quote
deeply offensive and harmful
and then just moved on without
addressing a single one of andrew
gutman's points
shut up and send your 60 grand that was
her response
you gotta wonder this is a scam
obviously but how much longer can this
scam
continue this game we pretend really is
an impressive place and the rest of them
collegiate spence pick your school
they're not impressive they're poisonous
so how long will we pretend they are
impressive
not much longer you've got to think